first I found out like what you had to
like make the center look like and then
I would look and then I found the same
base over 8,000 proteins out found your
bloodstream when you have these cancers
and if you can detect one of these
proteins then you could potentially
detect the cancer when survivals ads
best in the earliest stages but I was
looking and some of these proteins
didn't work so I went through all eight
thousand proteins on the four thousand
to try finally found one protein that
could work and then I came up with the
idea to how detect it in eighth grade
biology class this is meh cellent
mesothelin mesothelin yeah and so this
is the protein that is present when
someone has pancreatic cancer yes from
pancreatic ovarian and lung cancer and
also it's found the early stages when
survivals close to one hundred percent
ok so you dint ified the protein now you
have to figure out a test so that that
protein when it is in existence sort of
sets off like an alarm clock or a red
light exactly and how I do that is I use
where carbon nanotubes these are long
thin tubes of carbon there an atom thick
and 150 thousand the diameter of a
single strand of your hair so they're
extremely small and have these amazing
properties so combine those with these
other types of molecules called
antibodies and they're like a
lock-and-key they'll only react to that
one protein I was talking about
mesothelin you mix these up you get a
carbon substance I'll only react to that
protein they'll also change how
electricity flows through it based on
the amount of that protein present so
this electrical charge or this change in
the electrical charge kind of sets off
an alarm bell and then you would know
okay this is someone that has this
protein present that protein is present
when you have pancreatic cancer exactly
it's kind of a cow glucometer you just
take a drop blood put on its electrical
properties change and you have a meter
measure that change you send out 200
proposals right yeah to 200 different
places tell us what happened yeah so
that's one of the chapters in my book
breakthrough we're essentially i sent
out 200 proposals to all these different
labs at johns hopkins the National
Institutes of Health since I couldn't do
cancer research at my house and I sent
out this giant proposal and got 199
rejections and I
realized some professors aren't nearly
as nice those going profile pictures
make them seen there just like rip apart
and say I should just quit science now
since I've so bad at it but finally got
through that and got one positive
response from dr. in herb a Maitre johns
hopkins university and fortunately let
me work in his lab and seven months
later i created this paper sensor so you
create the paper sensor at Johns Hopkins
yeah are you surprised at the pushback
from those other 199 professionals in
this world of science yeah I mean I
could take my parents taught me know my
biology teacher talking about 109 I've
like the most prominent cancer
researchers that was a bit harder to
take but what really got me through that
is i really believe my idea and also i
mean the 100 people died of pancreatic
aim to every single day so i'd always
get up then can come when going help
save 100 lives today so that's why i
think when i got into a lab and when i
was getting all these rejections all
right the reason i bring that up is
because this idea of persevering and of
getting the access to the information is
something that you're working on is a
cause that you are promoting which is
you want people to get access to
information that the taxpayer is already
paid for exactly see because a ninety
percent of all scientific journals are
locked tightly behind these things
called pay walls that means when you
want access them you have to cough up
thirty-five dollars and even like
harvard university can't afford
sometimes these forty thousand dollars
per year subscriptions it's just
ridiculously overpriced and this is
really preventing a lot of people from
getting into science because we see like
all these big stem initiatives saying we
need more people in science but when
they katy perry single cost 99 cents a
seminal science article cost thirty-five
dollars that's a bit of a mixed message
and so right now i'm working on trying
to get access to all these different
articles give us an update on the test
for pancreatic cancer it seems like it
could be worked for other types of
cancers to exactly but that's one of the
most exciting parts about is it could be
broadly extended to any disease so you
could detect alzheimer's other forms of
cancer even hiv/aids and heart disease
the possibilities are literally endless
and right now I've been working to
further develop it for mass
manufacturing and getting it ready for
clinical trials and I
the international patent on it and talks
with a bunch of different biotech
companies about being on the market as
soon as possible so hopefully entering
clinical trial soon compare it to the
test that currently exists yes so the
initial test it costs eight hundred
dollars as grossly inaccurate missing
three percent of all cancers mine on the
other hand cost three cents in takes
five minutes to run and so far over
ninety percent accurate at detecting
these cancers in the earliest stages so
it's 168 times faster over 26,000 times
less expensive and over 400 times more
sense of than our current methods of
detection I asked Jack about the
scientist stereotype and what he likes
to do in his spare time in our segment
called get to know so a lot of people
have this perception I'm probably just
like only live in the lab but actually
do have a life so I do white work I
thing I was on the national junior while
bar team and I'm on my school's varsity
swim team and I always hang out with my
friends all the time they're really
great like different themed parties like
Pride and Prejudice parties and stuff so
I do have a life and science isn't like
science and having the life aren't
mutually exclusive you can have both and
you me a lot of great friends when
you're doing science you're you're
entering something soon right you're
empowering Stanford University yes yeah
yeah so I'm waiting to hear back from a
few colleges but pride going to be
stanford class of 20 19